très peu de temps après l'annnonce de
l'émergence de ce variant omicron
l'administration de joe biden avait
décidé d'interdire les voyageurs en
provenance de huit pays d'afrique
australe l'idée pour le locataire de la
maison blanche est de gagner du temps
parce qu'il sait qu'il y a un aspect
inéluctable et que ce variant finira tôt
ou tard par arriver sur le territoire
américain est d'ailleurs cette
conférence de presse donnée ce lundi
témoigne de l'importance accordée à
l'émergence de ce variant il y a des
inquiétudes oui et pas de panique selon
le locataire de la maison blanche
écouter
ce variant est une source d'inquiétude
il n'y a pas de raison de paniquer nous
disposons du meilleur vaccin au monde
des meilleurs médicaments des meilleurs
scientifiques et nous en apprenons
chaque jour davantage nous combattrons
ce variant par des actions scientifiques
et éclairé et avec rapidité et non dans
le chaos et la confusion spi 21 sièges
joe biden qui en a profité pour réitérer
ses appels à se faire vacciner il
encourage notamment les américains à
recourir à cette troisième dose qui est
désormais ouverte à toutes les personnes
de plus de 18 ans il n'y a pas de
nouvelles restrictions de voyages qui
sont prévus pour le moment selon le
locataire de la maison blanche d'où un
certain débat pourquoi ces pays
d'afrique australe sont concernés par
ces interdictions de voyager pas
d'autres pays où le variant mikron a
également été détectée aile joe biden
qui a également affirmé qu'il n'y aurait
pas de confinement puisque maintenant
les américains sont très largement
vacciner il va d'ailleurs détaillé ce
jeudi est la politique anti qu'ovide
menée par la maison blanche pour cette
période hivernale on sait qu'il est
conseillé par le docteur anthony fauci
qui a déclaré ce week-end qu'il fallait
peut-être se préparer à vivre avec le
virus parce que anthony fochi a quelques
doutes dit il sur le fait qu'il soit
possible d'éradiquer définitivement le
comique 19